Joe's a perfect fit for us and the fact
that you know he's a winner
he's played in a lot of big games he has
a lot of good football left in him at 34
years old feel like he's just really
coming into his prime so we're excited
the fact that he's gonna be our
quarterback you know if John Elway was
part of this show he'd be fined for
calling Joe Flacco a winner you're not
supposed to call a quarterback a win or
a quarterback either plays well or he
doesn't and Flacco at times guys has
played well but it feels like it's been
a long time since we've seen the best of
Joe Flacco Peter you spoke to John Elway
what doesn't always see in this guy and
and really why did he have to lock if he
sees so much in Joe Flacco there's a
couple of things Mike first of all I
want to tell you exactly what happened
in the Denver Broncos scouting process
and exactly what happened with the 10th
pick in this draft because that provides
some clarity about exactly where they
are right now first of all when they
went through the scouting process they
liked these quarterbacks they were not
absolutely in love had to have with any
one of them drew Locke was the number
one quarterback on their board in this
draft but they were determined
especially last week after watching
Flacco throw the ball in mini camp and
Vic Fangio don't forget that Fangio has
a major role Elway trusts him a lot both
watching quarterbacks and trying to
defend against quarterbacks Fangio
formerly on the Baltimore staff when
Flaco was there really likes Flacco's
mindset and his arm so Fangio said look
I am all-in with Joe you don't have to
take a quarterback and that really kind
of sculpted what the Denver Broncos were
going to do at number 10 now let's go to
the 10th pick in the draft if they had
stayed right where they were they would
have taken Michigan's Devon Bush the guy
who they traded out to Pittsburgh to
take so people say well wait a second if
they wanted to Evan Busch why didn't
they just take him there they were
trading it to a team that ended up
taking Devon Busch why
they do that it's because they didn't
feel like Devon Bush was the perfect
player for Vic Fangio system though they
would have taken him and they would have
liked him they didn't love him either so
they figured let's trade down they got a
three in 2020 they got Pittsburgh's
three and they get Noah Fant the tight
end at number 20 now the first round is
over I spent about 10 minutes with Elway
after the first round and I basically
said wow I really thought you might try
try to trade up because I had heard you
really like Drew lock it when he's there
all those teams at the end of the first
round want to trade out why didn't you
trade up and he goes we just like Joe so
much we just didn't really feel the need
to bring the guy in and to trade up and
to use draft capital to take the
quarterback at number 30 or 31 so the
next morning he comes in he and Matt
Russell is director of player personnel
and they start talking and they say man
you know the value on drew Locke is so
good right now they take Dalton there is
no number 41 and then make a trade up to
42 with Cincinnati to get drew luck it
isn't because they don't like flock or
don't think Flacco is gonna play the
next couple of years it is only because
they're saying at 42 if we can get the
best quarterback on our board we have
got to get him right here yeah it's
great it was a great move by them I mean
really I mean yes it was a little luck
but they got the future their franchise
and a guy that yeah I mean I think we
all thought Elway was hot on drew Locka
guy from the Senior Bowl on I mean
that's all the rumors you heard in the
NFL you know add to the fact that he has
a skillset that fits what they do on the
offensive side of the ball drew Locke as
far as rich gangrel ahooo comes from the
Kyle Shanahan offense with the play
actions and the boots so I'm sure that's
why they like Trulock because he is a
phenomenal athlete he can fit in that
offensive system you know in a lot of
ways also that I think that's why they
like Joe Flacco Joe Flacco I think
everybody's got to remember has
experience in the system too right guys
he was with Gary Kubiak a few years ago
in Baltimore the year they you know went
up to New England and
the divisional playoff game there's
still good years left in Joe Flacco I
don't always let you know like the
criticism that surrounds him you know
again he played for a football team for
that was not that great the last two
years didn't have great offensive
firepower around him I would question
some of the offensive minds he had
around him orchestrating his offenses
and I could see why John Elway and Vic
Fangio like some of the things Flacco
brings to the table he has played in a
lot of big-time football games I mean he
went first seven years he brought his
team to the playoffs there's something
to say about that and he was pretty
awesome in the Super Bowl too but I
think his skill set fits and he's still
a pretty good athlete for his age and
his arm is still special and I think
that's probably what Fangio and Elway
see in Flacco's game at this point yeah
Chris your dad was pretty awesome in the
Super Bowl as well but nobody's signing
him now I mean it was a long time ago
that Flacco was awesome in that Super
Bowl I think that's the problem recently
he hasn't been great they see something
there and I think the key ingredient is
going to be staying healthy you don't
want to give drew lock and opening and
guys there's an interesting comparison
here down the road
Daniel Jones number six overall to the
Giants drew lock number 42 to the
Broncos if lock ends up being the better
quarterback than John the already salty
Giants fans are going to be extra salty
but that's that's three or four seasons
away yeah I think that one point to make
about comparing these two guys Mike is
that it's all this was very much a
quarterback beauty in the eye of the
beholder draft okay why does John Elway
like lock over Jones why does he like
clock over Haskins you got to ask them
and you have to go through the process
with them and that's why Dave
gentleman's getting killed but Dave
gentlemen isolated and was myopically
convinced that this was his guy and as
he told me on Sunday he said we'll find
out if I'm crazy in three years well
took a look at mike Mayock first draft
with the raiders when PFE life continues
right after this
you
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports